has anyone ever um rejected you because
of your age
do they know before the date and oh oh
always yeah I think the only time you
get rejected is sometimes based on
Color Race religion culture those are
the things when all of a sudden things
change but age no I've never had a
problem with that I have actually been
rejected because of my age so I just
think like age is also equal to like
raise color like the same version and
stuff I've met older guys and they find
out that I'm like at the time what 18 19
20 whatever and they were like Oh no
you're too young so I think it's very
just very circumstantial but the
probability when you're younger that
you're not going to match with someone
about older than you is more likely like
I think with the mint chocolate idea
like like concept you're you're more
likely to like a mint chocolate that's
your own age you know I mean because
you're in the same stage of life more
likely but obviously there's going to be
those people those outliers that that
are that do match you have
um have any raise your hand other the
guys has a girl ever told you that
you're too young for her
ever
interesting okay I was just curious
you know I I you had a guy so four out
of five okay when you're asking that
question are you talking about now when
we were younger because ever I mean yeah
yeah yeah I don't know I just feel like
yes there's exceptions to the rule like
the minimals the one percent all of
these things that is fantastic ideally
would work fantastically but I the way I
look at a relationship is that you're
both running the same race separately
and then that means that you're more
likely to be successful you're both
running the same race separately yeah
the same way that you say people are the
same but they're different the same
difference that all that kind of thing
because it's like a parallel thing and
you're striving towards the same goal
which would be to raise a family to
obviously have a good relationship
together for the rest of your life
success blah blah blah blah blah and I
think it's much easier and I think it's
more you're more likely to succeed if
you are at similar stages and levels
because there's so much more
understanding in terms of even culture
in terms of social context and
everything so I just think you're more
likely to be more successful in that
with somebody that is closer to you in
so many more areas what do you think the
number one swiped right age is on dating
apps for men and for women if you've
heard this on the show before please
don't ruin it what are you okay what do
you think the number one swipe right so
like yes 22. ages for men and for women
both yeah
women is probably going to be like 32 no
I'll say 20 22 for women no women
um
start here and then go around
um for men I'll probably think 24 25 for
women
um 40.
I think guys would pick like
23 girls 32.
um men men 20 women 30 35 so I think men
are probably gonna pick like
22 23 I think guys are probably gonna go
for like
oh wait wait am I saying like guys are
going for them yeah so I think guys
we'll be going for like 25 year olds I
think women are going for like older
like 28 29 because they want the money
yeah okay I think most guys have money
by 28.29 yeah good
[Laughter]
um I think men are going for like
probably like 21 maybe even like 2019
and then girls are going for like 26.
okay uh girls are going out to 22 20 no
sorry guys are going for women who are
around 22 23 and I think women are going
for guys that are like 29 30.
I fit men are picking women
that are probably 22 23 and women are
going for guys
32 to 35.
me I think uh the men will go after the
girls who are
20 21 and then the girls are probably
going like 32 to be fair
yeah I'd say most swept women 22 most
swapped guys three
no one got it what is it I I was
actually really I didn't believe this
when I first saw it I I was shocked and
I'm I'm me you know
um the most swiped right age for a guy
um Did anyone say 40s anymore it's
actually older it's actually older than
that it's 50. wow
this was like uh funny this is it
couldn't be too I don't know if it was
plenty I could look it up I don't know
the exact app someone someone put in the
comments all right most swiped right for
girls
18. oh God
so all these guys want 18 year olds
I mean I would say I would say the most
desired
um
women are gold diggers
you know I've got big bum right here
you just sat right on me
should I address the elephant in the
room oh wow let us know take your hood
off stop hiding no I'm not hiding yeah
you are just the elephant in the room
hello
let it out quickly
do you see the elephant in a room
at 10 000 lakhs ten thousand lakhs we'll
address that see that late I love the
show though it's amazing
okay
I wonder what the elephant in the room
is I think well
I'm curious I hope it's nothing to do
with me
that's what it was like last time okay
um okay back to the decision um
what were we even talking about okay 18
and 50.
where he was he was saying
um people are swiping 18 year old girls
yeah I mean I think it's a typical I
mean why are models typically young like
men tend to like younger women women
tend to like older men women are
attracted to God that can protect and
provide um a man hits his financial
stride and it's like 40s or 50s men tend
to be attracted to fertility and youth I
don't think most guys like want to date
an 18 year old super like I don't I
don't talk to a lot of guys in real life
that say like their number one option is
18 like it seems to be more like 22 to
28 seems to be what guys I talk to
typically say but
um yeah I mean typically men go for
fertility and youth that's why they call
it Forever 21 not forever 50.
I think as Society becomes more
perpetuated on how people look younger
girls aren't going for us old guys
because I know in myself like I wouldn't
give someone super old because I
couldn't take your pictures with them
like like I I couldn't be as proud of
them and I think societies coming
feminized in that aspect
um yeah I mean that's what it's funny I
was really surprised by this I swear to
God when I saw this data I I was shocked
I I couldn't believe it because I was
like I don't know many girls that want
to date 50 year olds but that's what
they're swiping on them but you know
it's on Tinder then we have to consider
that so we'll get it or just to be a
sugar baby it's either match or Plenty
of Fish but either way
because Plenty of Fish
it's crazy
but it's because of the way people are
using dating apps people don't actually
use deity apps to get married okay so
that's that's what you would think right
but it's actually it's actually the
number one way people meet today
that's the number one so so ladies and
gentlemen that's why we have issues
no you're you're you're right you're
right but I'm saying like that's if
that's the number one way long-term
relation chips are forming nowadays and
that's what men and women are swiping on
that says something
and some some apps are a little
different but they're only different by
like a couple years it's really not that
different is it like dating apps are
kind of like corn they over exaggerate
the reality of things you I when you're
going on on dating apps you can actually
be in touch with an 18 year old where in
reality if you're a 50 year old man
hanging around 18 year old you're a
weirdo so that's okay if you're if
you're hot you're hot like hot girls get
swiped say like it it doesn't at what
age it doesn't matter but but the point
is in general men tend to like younger
women and in general women tend to like
older men but the exaggeration of the 18
is just an exact it's just showing it
it's not very good and that's what
people are seeing and they're looking at
it oh it's not very good it's not a very
good example to send it's not actually
something great it's not bad because why
is it not because I think that these
stats are things that there's they're
part of what I would say a certain
fantasy and idealization of what people
think they dating is and you and then
they almost become a reality and it
stops it but it is what it is you can't
no I'm saying you're painting if if we
ask the married people how did you meet
your spouse and they say dating apps and
then we go to the dating apps and say
okay what ages are people swiping on I
have to agree how is that deleting
reality no that what that is doing is
just showing how twisted it is so
basically there's a lot of men that go
in looking for young girls online 18 not
even 22 or 23 18 blood but I think
I love it why does that matter
it does matter it does matter because
it's the same thing that I keep saying
like is this fantasy this fantasization
guys so if you if you've taken anything
from this conversation guys don't really
care about age like the number it's just
are you hot are you not
young girls
like I think what you're trying to
emphasize is that like that for women
there's a lot more of an idolization for
youth like when it's with men it's not
as attached like as as women get older a
lot of people think oh they're not as
smart they're not as their advice isn't
as helpful but when men get older
they're more wise they're more helpful
like like you always hear the wise man
story you don't hear the wise woman
story do you yeah okay so basically they
don't like wrinkles yeah in a way
because it displays that you're not as
fertile in and and I think that's what
Pearl would say but that's an average
woman knows that herself because I mean
it's just clear that you guys obviously
put so much more attention money into
your parents we spent we spend 300 000
more in a Lifetime on beauty products
and I mean like why why do we get why do
we get lip filler why do we get BOTOX
why do we get all of this stuff to look
younger beautiful women get better men
that pay for a nicer lifestyle so yeah
yeah also are these guys even looking at
the age because they could just be
seeing Young
I mean we all know those people that
peaked in high school and like and you
know now they look like a mini whale or
a beluga whale you know
so but I just want to be clear so like
this you keep on saying go the younger a
girl is the hotter she is so it's like I
genuinely don't think in hotness there's
a massive like I actually think girls in
their 20s like mid like just early 20s
mid 20s late 20s they look better than
18 year olds they know they have money
they know how to do their makeup they
don't have to like this idea 18 year
olds yeah 18 year olds look better than
any girl in it I think that's yeah they
in that profile picture will just be
like a boohoo dress or something so yeah
know honestly if you're a date and 18
year old that doesn't look great you can
just influence her to dress how you
think is better I mean they they say
it's like 18 to 28 is like when a
woman's sexual peak is like these are
her best years and and it's kind of it's
it seems to be kind of similar with the
answers to the guy that the guys gave
um they I mean according to this this
date like it depends who you ask
this said 50 was the number one age
swiped right on um anecdotally I would
guess mid-30s early 40s I would say
because then I mean because you have all
the girls that are younger than you you
take a bigger pool I'd imagine but I I
feel like the um the data is cute though
in a sense though
um
from personal experience
the younger you go the more options you
have as in people actually using these
dating apps
um so there's probably like a smaller
pool of like people probably above 25
fee you are looking for certain serious
and there's a lot more like you know
you've got your computer and people in
universities so there's like a if
there's going to be like I don't know
40 of the total 100 in University then
chances are the 18 year old kind of that
makes more sense yeah you are right yeah
I'm saying in terms of people going for
that because
um I use I think hinge like a couple
months ago and I set my preference
um I think my lower end was like 23 and
you ran out of options but then when you
drop it down to 22 all of a sudden it's
just flooded I mean so I think there's
also some sort of skewing in terms of
that statistics because all domain here
for me is just generally like 20 at the
age I'm at I know that nearly every man
that I I know is gonna 22 23 22's a bit
too young but that 23 is at the ideal
age
um and then the older you get I guess it
just kind of
stays around there and then goes up a
bit completely like I don't know like
more people that are young use dating
apps like more 18 to 21 year olds use
dating apps more than you would say like
a 28 to 30 year old because they're
looking for like people roughly that age
and I don't know people that younger use
the internet more often and stuff like
you don't get like many 40 year olds
like on dating apps I don't think
personally just from my personal
experience yeah so how about does the
data basically exactly how accurate is
it it doesn't show like a complete like
representation of all the different ages
I just think the point is that men tend
to like younger women and women tend to
like older men even if the data is a bit
off by like five years like let's give
it five ten years it's still it's still
the general conclusion is still going to
be the same to be it's 18 and 50. I'm
not gonna lie I kind of let me tell you
the truth that I must admit I agree with
you now pal
I always said that I want my man to be
older than me even if it's by one year
because that one year alone will be able
to give this nice room where I can give
him another sort of respect above me
because submission for me is difficult
so I need to find the apartment
helps
me that helps not because I want his
money but because it will allow me to
actually give him the respect that he is
looking for as a man naturally without
having to like fake it women tend to
like um like guys five to seven years
older than them
and then there's another study which was
closer to 22 where they asked men like
when they found that women the most
attractive between the ages of like 18
and like 70 and they all said 22. so
it's it's you know different studies
will give it but it's it's generally for
women between 18 and 25. as many of you
know I was just banned on Tick Tock and
demonetized on a daily basis
if you want to help please consider
sending a super thanks below every
donation helps and it helps make what we
do possible